the first thing i want to show you is a
story from fox news
biden still hasn't held a press
conference after 43 days in office
the subhead for the fox news article
says quote i think his people keep him
away from the media
because they're afraid he might trail
off or have difficulty answering basic
questions
which brings me to this video clip from
the first
check this out i'm going to play this
for you and i'm happy to take questions
if that's you i'm supposed to do nance
whatever you want me to do
and just for those listening the fee
just cuts out
and then it says thank you for joining
so it wasn't an accident there's no way
it's as president biden participates in
a virtual event with the house
democratic caucus
it just turns off that's it so again not
only has biden not called a press
conference
like apparently his handlers aren't
allowing him to do it and i don't mean
handle like some grand conspiracy where
he's the manchurian candidate or
something
i mean literally like the people working
with them are like come on biden it's
time to go to bed
they put him in the wheelchair with the
blanket on his lap and he goes and they
cart him away
and uh this is what we saw today so it
was this clip jack
dex like you see this clip check this
out and then you i think you asked about
the state of union right
yeah and then we just started digging
doing some real investigative journalism
over here
trying to figure out what's really going
on you know if i got elected president
and i had been
vice president and i had been the one
sitting in the chair
up behind the president all those times
listening applauding like a seal every
time the president said standing up when
you're supposed to
if i had my chance to finally be the guy
giving the speech with the two people
behind me cheering me on and clapping me
on and the whole nation watching and
joint session of congress state of the
union address i'm the
president of the united states i'd be
trying to schedule that thing day after
freaking
honor inauguration let me let me pull
the dates
so we go back to 2017. the first thing
was first question we asked was okay
well it's it's his first year in office
do they give a state of the union
address like within a month
of being inaugurated donald trump
february 28 2017.
okay that was his first public address
it was donald trump's speech to the
joint session of congress
all right well well trump did it so then
oh let's go back to
obama 2009 obama's speech to joint
section of congress february 24th
all right well what about george w bush
so we tried searching wikipedia sure
enough there's nothing listed
why because bush didn't call it a state
of the union
but on february 27th he held an address
to the joint session of congress
all right well let's go back even
further we have
bill clinton president's address to the
joint session
1993 state of the union february 17th
william j clinton presidential library
all right then we've got
february 9th 1989 the scene bush senior
we go back to the reagan library
february 18th 1981
and then we stop here president carter
1977
april 20th but i believe the date is
actually listed as april 18th
in in media but we have here from the
history art and archives this is
house.gov
saying april 20th 1977.
that's how far back you have to go in
order to find a time where a president
has gone this long
without giving a state of the union or
joint
a speech to the joint session of
congress so again not
unprecedented just it's been a really
long time in my lifetime and i'm old
yeah it's been in my lifetime and i'm
old and it didn't happen it hasn't
happened why not wouldn't you be excited
to do it yeah this is a different
generation it's a different time he
should be
giving youtube making youtube videos if
not daily weekly
well yes that's of course a social media
strategy is something that they all
should really be employing and they're
not and trump should have been doing
that and he didn't
however come on i mean he kind of did
but it wasn't i wouldn't call it a
strategy you know what i mean well i
just
i wish and and guys in our circle have
been calling for this he should have
been doing periscopes he should have
been doing
live streams he should have been letting
people in on the inside and going direct
but anyway
another topic for conversation jimmy
carter uh
joe biden here joe biden he i don't
think
has the stamina to stand up there does
he no that's
i think that's it that's why they won't
let him answer questions you know why
when he said in that video he's like
i'll take some questions
they're going to go um president biden
and then they're going to call out
something like
cuomo people dead in nursing homes and
he's going to go oh
drew it on a shop with and then people
are going to be like uh it's been a
while since i've heard his voice and
when you played that he sounded
just haggard well haggar who's nancy
he asked he's like i'll i'll take some
questions if that's what i'm going to do
nancy it was the house democratic
isn't she older than he is she is but
she does seem to be a little bit more
lucid
spry yeah she's pretty yeah botox
i don't know if that's keeping her going
but so i think biden got an eyelid is
that what that's called
yeah yeah probably he got a lot of work
done and he's a really old guy well
imagine what you know you saw what
happened to
obama you saw what happened to bush and
reagan how the presidency
ages people yeah dude it did not age
trump i noticed that did not
did not age trump at all as a matter of
fact anything had aged him
but biden though he may just
disintegrate
did you see the was it the onion article
i think where it was like
uh presidency ages bited in first term
it was a picture of like a corpse just
totally rotted like the
the crypt keeper from all the hbo i
don't know maybe
maybe uh trigger warning yeah
because the image is hilarious oh boy do
we
stress oh my gosh pull it up the stress
of presidency already ages by intention
and it's just a mummified bite and like
but like a joint session of congress
where the president
addresses them and the nation on every
network everybody stops everything to
pay attention
that is a major moment for america right
and
what a time right now we're in
don't you think with january 6 that we
need to heal
and all this stuff unify and get past
the election
don't you think that this more than ever
should be a time for the president
to address everyone everyone but let's
be honest do you really think
joe biden getting up before a joint
state of congress and spouting out
true and on a shabbat of pressure is
going to unite people i mean
look it's funny i use i use that word
because i don't know what else
word you use to describe his inability
to speak but that one or batacath care
he's going to get up there and he's
going to be like my father my fellow
mexicans americans my fellow
uh uh uh you know
the people in the country uh
but that's but it's state of the union
they've got the teleprompters
there's no questions we're in a national
crisis
the cut the city is under siege and
occupied
there's barbed wire fences around the
capitol now to take the other counter
position
perhaps this is and i hate doing this
taking the other position perhaps though
this is congruent with the state of
emergency in the district of columbia
the national guard presence potential
threats of march
4th new people storming the capital
maybe it's just too high of a security
risk but
wouldn't they say that wouldn't they
even just come out and be like too high
security risks they're going to
postpone it dude that video creeps me
out the video where biden's talking and
they turn the camera off i'm like
he's like i'll do it i'll take questions
i'll take some questions can i please
can i plea
what i'm just imagining like he's
sitting there and like
xi jinping is like he's like standing
with his arms crossed by the camera
and then when he's like i'll answer
questions he goes and they cut it off
and it's like
i'm kidding about gnp i'm just saying
like
when joe biden is on camera saying i'll
do the questions and then someone turns
it off
who right just turned the president of
these united states off
in an address to the democratic congress
a caucus
who did that who overrode the president
himself
that is freaking me out imagine if that
happened with trump i'll take some
questions and people started to turn it
off
no the joke the joke you know they
turned off andrew yang's mic in the
democratic debate
did they yeah yeah yeah yeah because you
could watch him he's talking and he's
like
i'm here to talk about universal basic
and then you see him like very faintly
from the other microphones and his mouth
was moving
trump would grab the other person's mic
and go excuse me excuse me
you don't turn my microphone off no no
listen i'm talking
right right shut them all down right
biden does not
have the fight in him you turn the
cameras off
could you imagine the present dude i
need to stress this to all of you
listening at home
my fellow americans the president
of the united states was speaking to
members of congress
and offered to answer questions and then
abruptly and without any communication
from the president
someone disconnected his communications
who
overrode the president what network was
it on it was at whitehouse.gov
wow whitehouse.gov turned his cam made
this is
i'm gonna say right now in case i'm
getting punked is the video fake
it was posted by a bunch of verified
people it was posted by the first on tv
it's a it's like a tv network
so what is this okay are we being are we
being punked right now and this video is
gonna go viral with all these left is
being like
dummy is he thought it was real i don't
know it's congruent
which makes it believable that's a scary
thing right it's totally congruent
outside of that whole scenario the
bigger picture is no state of the union
address no press conferences
nope right it's sad the way he even was
like i guess i'll take questions now if
that's what i'm supposed he was like
willing like what old miserable
loose he's obviously clearly not in
control
no he's not in control of the things he
says the way he spends his time
the way he can communicate to the
american people most likely
in his decision making about what
politics are doing so let's tie this
together
remember the syrian strikes a few days
ago yep
kamala harris apparently was answering
phone calls for him
but but apparently kamala harris did not
even know she was not told
she was upset that she wasn't in the
loop right
who knew who made the decision
who is controlling joe biden you know
trump changed some of the laws regarding
drone strikes and gave
control of that to the military so it
could have been people in the military
making the decision
look at this look at this story veep
kamala harris takes foreign calls on
behalf of joe biden february 16th
geez some something creepy man um
and i'll say this i'll say this in the
video where joe biden is speaking
i'm willing to bet that's a green screen
behind him
that's right i'm half kidding i think it
is a green screen but it's not like a
nefarious green screen i think it's just
because he's doing a zoom call or
something
right but it does kind of look like he's
sitting at a green screen
why did america elect grandpa
who should be in a nursing home in new
york city
because of hatred because of their
hatred for donald trump
they voted for him out of hatred and now
they got an idiot his pr no he's not an
idiot he's just old
yeah what if the simulation is just
breaking you know
like like you ever see the rick and
morty episode where they turn the the
simulation computing power down
for jerry to like five percent and then
nobody is talking but he believes it
like people are saying
yes and my man like they're not actually
interacting with him but he just thinks
it's all real
like we're sitting here and joe biden's
like i'll answer your questions now the
camera turns off and we're like oh
that's normal
there are americans thinking that's
normal that's the weirdest thing to me
what who are you you peop you you all
sitting there listening to this podcast
you people
you people you you podcast listeners oh
yeah how many of you are sitting there
going like well that was normal
no is anybody thinking that
only only people who are willingly
convincing themselves to believe
unreality so that they can get rid of
orange man bad all this
fits with something that i said here uh
back in november
which is that the the democratic people
were just beaten into submission
yeah and they and now they're willing to
accept total insanity oh yeah in order
to just relieve
the pressure like jennifer rubin right
from the washington post
the other day she tweets out she's like
it's such a great day where i don't have
to think about politics on the weekend
or whatever i'm sleeping in late
sleeping in late even she is like
feeling the relief of not being beaten
over the head all day by horrible
horrible terrible things
and it's like man these what is that
this is accepted that is
this is the you know that is jack yeah
you wear this thing and it protects you
from covid
it's like i don't know it has a vent on
it yeah can you put it on with the
headphones on the same time i don't
think so but i'll show you did you
see the the people with the big green
plastic boxes over there
don't don't that's the new normal don't
say people say
pod people children animals oh yeah
those are children
in school my friend i just saw two
people in the woods
with them on no so for for people who
are just listening and can't see
like what's happening ian is wearing
this weird like sp
you got to turn it on otherwise it's on
now it's fogging up
it's venting for me ian's wearing this
big plastic space helmet dome
thing that we have it's going to protect
me from cloven
a living apparently that's it that's it
the crazy thing is you joe biden
just said apparently i i at some kind of
like uh
you know interestingly they're saying he
didn't do a press conference but he has
answered questions
because he was asked about uh by a
journalist about how long were to be
locked down he said i can't give you an
answer but maybe this time next year
next year right at the same time greg
abbott completely opens up texas
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time